the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video today I want to take a look at
the script for the Game of Thrones
Season 8 finale the Iron Throne
some of you may not know this but they
did release the entire script for the
final episode a few days ago I was only
able to glance at it so far but I will
go through some of the things as I'm
making the video because I didn't notice
there were some interesting details
about that final episode I know many of
you were wondering why some things
happen the way they did during the
finale so hopefully this will give us
some of those answers now unfortunately
as I was making the video the emmys
website is no longer giving me access to
the script I wanted to show it on the
screen as I was reading it but now I'm
not gonna be able to do that so fully
you're all just gonna be able to take my
word for it if any of you know another
website that is hosting it let me know
so I can add the link down below now
let's go ahead and get started right
away the very first thing I want to
discuss is literally in the first
sentence it says snow has begun to fall
and will continue to fall throughout
this day now most of you should remember
right after the episode aired there was
a big debate about what was actually
covering the Iron Throne when Danny was
inside the Great Hall at the red key I
know I certainly went back and forth
with many of you about this on social
media ever since we saw Daenerys
Targaryen vision at the house of the
undying I've always said that was snow
falling on the Iron Throne whereas many
fans said it was ash from all the fires
burning throughout the city either one
of those answers make sense but I think
only one of them is actually right now
obviously there is some fallen ash
laying all around the city but if we
take a look at the actual scene I think
we can finally confirm what this is
falling from the sky let's go to the
scene with the Iron Throne
it says Dany stands in the throne room
and it looks just like it did in her
vision only the area behind the Iron
Throne has been destroyed altogether the
snow falls lightly through the collapsed
roof as she steps past the pillars down
the central aisle rubble from the Fallen
roof is visible on the floor covered in
a
layer of snow so as you can see that is
without a doubt snow falling from the
sky onto the Iron Throne just like in
Danny's vision this is one debate we can
finally lay to rest now let's go ahead
and look at what happens later in the
same scene as you all know right after
Jon Snow stabs Daenerys Targaryen drug
on flies into the room where he then
begins to melt down the Iron Throne with
his dragon flame this is another thing
from that episode that led to a debate
within the community
there were many theories surrounding why
Drogo and decided to do that but now
that this has been released we can
finally have the correct answer I'll be
the first one to say the answer is not
very exciting or interesting at all but
at least now we will know why let's see
what actually happened when drug on
released his fire it says he looks down
at Jon we see the fire built up in his
throat Jon sees it as well he prepares
to die but the blast is not for him
drogon wants to burn the world but he
will not kill Jon he breathes fire at
the back wall blasting down what remains
of the great red blocks of stone we look
over John's shoulder as the fire sweeps
toward the Iron Throne not the target of
dragons wrath just a dumb bystander
caught up in the conflagration we look
through the blades of the throne as the
flames engulf it and blast the wall
behind it so as you can see dragon did
not intentionally burn down the Iron
Throne it essentially happened simply
because it was sitting in the same
direction drag almost facing when he let
out the fire I know many fans were
thinking maybe drug on did that because
he's so smart he realizes it's what led
to Danny's downfall but that does not
seem to be the case at all this is
another debate we can finally lay to
rest I got to be honest I wish there was
a deeper meaning behind dragon burning
the Iron Throne saying that it was an
accident kind of sucks but this is
another explanation we're just gonna
have to live with until we see how
things unfold in the books I was also
hoping they would say exactly where
Dragon was taken Danny's body but it
wasn't very specific it only said he was
heading east now there were a few other
things I wanted to discuss but like I
said I wasn't able to make notes of
everything before the emmys website had
it taken down I do know that one of the
other things had to do with John and
Arya I can't remember exactly what it
said but I know it implied they would
never see each other again now obviously
they were heading in different
directions but I was hoping they would
reunite eventually I like it to be a
little more open and
that way I can imagine what would happen
years down the road if the story
continued but when it comes to John and
Aria at least in Danaan days version of
the events they wanted this to be the
last time John and Oreo would ever see
each other that also kind of sucks but
it is what it is
anyways I mainly wanted to make the
video just so I could show you what it
said about the Iron Throne scene in
particular that was obviously a major
event in this series because it did
determine the fate of two of our main
characters now we can't confirm that it
was indeed snow falling on the Iron
Throne
just like in Danny's vision and there
was no specific reason why drug on
melted down the Iron Throne let me know
your thoughts on this also let me know
if you were able to see it before the
Emmys web site had it removed if there
was anything else you wanted to discuss
just leave it down below I want to thank
everyone for stopping by to watch the
video and I also want to thank everyone
for supporting the channel I hope you
all have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]